617 830 4750 is the number let's go to
is going to be our last caller today
from the 248 area code caller what is
your name and where you calling from hey
this is a Cameron on calling Hong flash
again great what's behind it hey I'm
really just reaching out because I've
spent a lot of time trying to look at
this the American Health Care Act and um
I really don't understand what they're
in game is and and I'm I'm just trying
I'm live interested in what you think
because it's like it's like they're
walking up to a base we're gonna Brett
swinging a bat and just walking away is
like I don't really know what you're
looking to accomplish yeah they just
threw a bunch of stuff but like I would
have just faked it like I would have
just did I would have just did something
that required to 60 volts said we try
for 48 years and walk away yes I don't
know listen here's where I think the
goal is clear i think is going on
there's a couple different things one is
you need to somehow make good on the
campaign promise and on what republicans
have been trying to do for 67 years now
which is repeal obamacare so in some way
you've got to check that box that's
number one number two Republicans want
to say that they cut taxes so removing
subsidies and replacing them with tax
credits is a way to say we cut taxes
even though the net effect is going to
be an increase in out-of-pocket health
care costs via premiums etc etc
particularly for seniors okay and then
obviously in addition to this you want
to give insurance companies big
corporations more power and I've been
critical of the Affordable Care Act
because it gave you know 20 20 million
or more than 20 million new customers to
for-profit insurance companies and
further locked us into that paradigm but
that's another aspect of what would
happen with the American Health Care Act
which is more money and more
decision-making power and freedom lack
of regulation to insurance companies and
also take down government structures
when you when you shrink Medicare and
Medicaid in any way the number of people
on it the benefit
whatever you're pushing this this sort
of amorphous notion of smaller
government so I think these are some of
the different priorities of the aah a
different Republicans have different
priorities in terms of what's most
important to them but that's part of the
big picture of what's going on here I
you know I will say that I i would i
would hope that uh it that the American
people including Trump supporters would
actually take the time to understand
what's in the bill you understand
exactly what it is that'd be nice um
because it doesn't really seem to
benefit definitely seem to benefit to
pour it on it doesn't and it not only
thing only set of people really seemed
to benefited the ultra-rich or yeah you
know there's just some minor benefits
for younger people will be on that it
doesn't really do anything for anyone
beyond the rich and I just don't
understand okay listen quick question
while I have you on the phone what's up
with your drinking water are you what's
the current situation in Flint it's it's
it's a situation that's there's a whole
pot of confusion in all honesty among
most of the residents in the plant and
it's mainly because I just be
conflicting media reports about what
actually is in the water and in what
safe to do with it for a long time I
even talked about it's okay to bathe in
it but now we're understanding because
some other chemicals involved in the
water that might not be a good yes yeah
so I mean it's just just feel like it
just years later just feel like a whole
entire plane of confusion and though
there has been a very very very tiny
amount of progress made it this city is
critical yeah you know all right well
thanks I really appreciate the call
we're going to keep covering the Flint
water situation and that's going to do
it for calls today thanks to everybody
who called we will take calls again that
I promise you